وبشان الموقف من الازمه السوريه اكد رئيس
الوزراء القطري الشيخ محمد بن عبد الرحمن
اللساني ان الاسباب التي دفعت قطر لدعم
تعليق عضويه سوريا في الجامعه العربيه لا
تزال قائمه
كان هناك اسباب لتعليقيه سوريا في الجامعه
العربيه
والتعامل مقاطعه النظام السوري
في ذاك الوقت وهذه الاسباب ما زالت قائمه
بالنسبه للاقل في دوله قطر صحيح ان الحرب
توقفت ولكن الشعب السوري ما زال مهجر في
الناس يعني ابرياء في السجون في اشياء
كثيره احنا
لا نريد فرض حلول على الشعب السوري الشعب
السوري هو اللي راح يعني يجب ان يوصل للحل
يجب انه يكون في حل سياسي للعزمه السوريه
دوله قطر قرارها كدوله منفرد هو ان لا
تتخذ اي خطوه اذا ما في تقدم سياسي ما في
يعني حل سياسي
[موسيقى]
الازمه السوريه